Imagine duas pessoas a começar o mesmo trabalho no mesmo dia.
Cinco anos depois, uma tornou-se líder.
A outra continua a fazer o mesmo trabalho da mesma forma.
O que fez a diferença?
Geralmente, não foi talento, foi a aprendizagem.
As pessoas que crescem mais depressa são as pessoas que nunca deixam de aprender.
Mantém-se curiosas, fazem perguntas, estudam, escutam,
procuram formas melhores de fazer as coisas.
São aprendizes para a vida.
Um aprendiz para a vida não diz, eu já sei.
Em vez disso, pergunta.
O que posso aprender hoje?
Todos os dias são uma oportunidade para melhorar.
Talvez aprenda uma nova competência.
Talvez aprenda com um erro.
Talvez aprenda com um colega de equipa.
Talvez aprenda com a IA.
Talvez aprenda observando alguém com mais experiência do que si.
Cada lição torna o mais forte.
Aqui está algo importante.
Fazer perguntas não é sinal de fraqueza.
É sinal de sabedoria.
Se não tem a certeza, pergunte.
Se não percebe, pergunte.
Se vir alguém a fazer algo melhor do que si, peça-lhe que o ensine.
A maioria das pessoas tem prazer em partilhar o que sabe.
Uma boa pergunta hoje pode poupar-lhe muitas horas amanhã.
Vamos pensar numa criança.
As crianças aprendem depressa porque são curiosas.
Fazem perguntas.
Experimentam coisas novas.
Não se envergonham de dizer, não sei.
Como adultos, nunca devíamos perder essa atitude.
Mantenha-se curioso.
Mantenha-se disponível para aprender.
Mantenha-se com fome de aprender.
Aqui está um hábito simples que pode usar todos os dias.
No final do seu dia de trabalho, faça-se próprio três perguntas.
O que aprendi hoje?
Que erro me ensinou algo?
O que vou fazer melhor amanhã?
Se responder a estas perguntas todos os dias, vai continuar a crescer.
Lembre-se, a aprendizagem não acontece só numa sala de aula.
Aprende-se a ler.
Aprende-se a escutar.
Aprende-se a observar.
Aprende-se a fazer.
Aprende-se a perguntar.
E hoje também pode aprender com a IA.
Antes de terminar uma tarefa, pergunte a IA.
Como poderia melhorar isto?
O que é que falhei?
Há uma forma melhor?
Pense na IA como um treinador que está disponível a qualquer altura.
Use-a.
Mas não fique por aí.
Aprende-se com seus colegas de equipa.
Aprende-se com seus líderes.
Aprende-se com pessoas com mais experiência.
Aprende-se com seus próprios sucessos.
Aprende-se com seus próprios erros.
As pessoas que têm sucesso na vida não são as pessoas que sabem tudo.
São as pessoas que nunca deixam de aprender.
Aqui está um último pensamento.
O seu maior investimento não é uma máquina.
Não é um edifício.
Nem sequer é um negócio.
O seu maior investimento é você próprio.
Cada nova competência que aprende fica consigo.
Cada lição torna o mais valioso.
Cada dia em que escolhe aprender, torna-se melhor do que era ontem.
Por isso, faça disto o seu hábito.
Seja curioso.
Faça perguntas.
Estude.
Pratique.
Escute.
Aprenda.
E nunca deixe de crescer.
Porque o dia em que deixar de aprender é o dia em que deixa de melhorar.
Mas se se tornar um aprendiz para a vida, o seu potencial não tem limite.